when coronavirus struck it triggered a
global scramble
for personal protective equipment under
pressure to source
every bit of ppe it could from wherever
it could be found the british
government's pandemic procurement effort
took it to an unlikely source
american jewelry designer michael saga
based in florida he has shops in new
york and los
angeles and crucially contacts
in china that convinced the department
of health
to award him six contracts worth up to
299 million pounds
those contracts are now the subject of a
legal dispute in the united states
between mr sega and a spanish
businessman
he recruited to help with distribution
they show that as part of the first
contract
gabrielle gonzalez anderson was paid
28 million dollars that's around
21 million pounds campaigners the good
law group
are now challenging the contract awarded
without competitive tender
in the british courts the really
remarkable thing about that story
is that it tells us quite how much money
people are making how much profit there
is in this
pandemic for the well-connected in those
contracts there was enough for
uh mr anderson to make 50 50 million
and there was also enough for mr sega to
make a no doubt substantial profit as
well
these are vast fortunes being made at
public expense
the revelations come with the government
accused of cronyism over senior
appointments
and the award of contracts during the
pandemic
prompting heated exchanges in the
commons
this was outlined in the ppe strategy
published on the 28th of september
children thank you right
rachel mr churchill i think it's done to
me you career
thank you very much mr speaker i'm sorry
it's that old habit of being a mother of
four
tonight the department of health said it
couldn't comment
on legal proceedings while mr sega said
he was guilty of nothing
except enterprise insisting his
contracts
had delivered for britain on time
and at value paul kelso sky news